welcome back Hannity joining us a man is
now a man who needs no introduction
author up now the best-selling book
Killeen England the brutal struggle for
American independence Bill O'Reilly how
are you it's here I'm alive all the way
back like you did it the people want to
see it yeah well it's good thank you how
are you and and do you miss the daily
grind of no I'm as in the ocean all
summer and I had a great time I'm fine
I'm teed off but first I want to tell
everybody but last night Hannity kicked
MSNBC's but he's taken over my second
then stop okay didn't beat that woman
didn't didn't eat by slaughtered her and
here's a reason the people and I'm a
person I know some people don't believe
that are angry about this NFL because a
much bigger story than football players
and I want to address this comment to
the NFL players today and they'll get
this when the Jaguars and the Ravens
were over in London and they kneeled
down on a foreign soil and then they
stood up for the British National God
Save the Queen I was angry and sad
because I don't believe those players
know what they're doing about 3,000
miles east of you there are American
military people in Kandahar Afghanistan
whose entertainment revolves around the
Armed Forces Network that broadcasts
football games now I was over there in
seven I watched football games with them
can you imagine putting your life on the
line in Afghanistan and having just a
leisure time and wanting to watch a
football game and seeing your players
your American players disrespect the
country and the flag on foreign soil can
you imagine how painful it was how could
they possibly not know they don't why do
you give it these don't most of these
these players do up there the best of
the best I have great respect for their
athletic talent their ability their
agility the hard work
yet they went to college bill mostly
kids play college ball it's a mob
mentality
it is a anti-trump demonstration that's
what it's morphed into but there's two
kinds of dissent and nobody nobody is
saying the players don't have a right to
their opinion about life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness they do you and if
you want to feel America is an evil
country where the white supremacists
stalk innocent blacks if you want to
believe that you're free to believe it
but it's not true it's not true
so there's informed dissent and then
there's PAC Minson dissent when that's
where we're into now PAC dissent okay so
he says one thing I say another and the
league and the owners have lost control
of it but the American people I firmly
believe 65% maybe 70% of the American
people do not like this situation are
offended by this situation how much of
this is related I played President Obama
he rushed to judgment when it came to
Baltimore and Freddie gray and it never
happened hands up don't shoot and
Trayvon Martin and George Zimmerman now
I learned when I was in Atlanta local
radio guy you don't rush to judgment
that was in the Richard Jewell case but
the president at the time rush to
judgment that narrative people believe
hands up don't shoot happen a lot of
people believe propaganda and there's
nothing we can do about it I mean one of
the reasons I wrote killing England is
that everybody can now know what really
happened that how we got our freedom I'd
love to go to every NFL locker room and
give these guys the book would they read
the book most of them would not because
again they're caught up in emotion this
is emotion what's happening now but the
wider picture is and you pointed it out
in your monologue the far left wants to
drive the narrative that the USA is an
evil country why they want to change
everything the Constitution the economic
system the leadership the electoral
system they want across-the-board change
I want to get into those stuff like this
to use it these players are being used
where does this in your opinion all in I
think they're in a
quandary they're in a dilemma now we
kind of tried to see the Dallas Cowboys
last night threading threading a needle
look at the average family I grew up in
a small Cape Cod house three older
sisters one bathroom by the way bill
that that's hell on earth fifty lot
seriously
Franklin square you know where I grew up
yeah I grew up there if you take a
family affordable to a football game
basketball game baseball game all right
average ticket about a hundred grand
okay it's close to hot dogs yeah you buy
a TA you buy a Jersey right you buy all
the stuff it's it's so much money and
people literally sacrifice and save for
that how are they gonna react how does
this end well first of all the Lea is
gonna have to do something and what they
should do is they wrote I wrote a column
for the hill about it is say to the
players we know that some of you don't
like the country or I want to get a
point across but this is the wrong forum
all right this is not the forum to do it
so if you don't want to stand up for the
national anthem stay in the locker room
and then come out we don't want any
political demonstrations because we
don't allow pro-american demonstrations
the league does not allow that there
were many many giant players New York
giant jet players that after 9/11 wanted
to show on their universally this
solidarity this would allow it we have
the slaughter of cops in Dallas wanted
to honor the local police come on
they're gonna let them they wouldn't let
them so you've got to be consistent so
the league it says all right you guys
who don't want to stand up for the
national anthem you stay in a locker
room after it's over you can come out
that's it okay all right well it would
be certainly it wouldn't be selective
enforcement of the rules let me ask you
a broader bigger question because you
talked about this for many years on your
show I know you have your podcast now in
your columns but every two and four
years and then when we have these other
bigger issues emerged the issue of race
it is used as a wedge issue
so the Missouri radio ad that said if
you elect Republicans black churches are
going to burn the James Byrd and Al Gore
saying when he's running for president
to a predominantly black audience
Republicans have the raw
agenda for african-americans changing
his cadence they don't even want to
count you in the census that is a lie
and it divides the country and it's
dividing the country along racial lines
in a way that solutely is hurtful to the
country and then the media drives it and
the entertainers drive it but there is a
reason why it's happening
a year ago you did not hear the words
white supremists didn't hear it nobody
heard it it was white privilege and in
my Levittown neighborhood about 8 miles
away from Hannity's Franklin's mother
was miles away the guys you know in
undershirts that are my white privilige
alright okay that's what you had a year
ago it's morphed into white supremacists
now and people are buying it why because
the far-left agents and i think they're
evil want to destroy the Constitution in
the sense that they want it all changed
it who forged that slave-owners Thomas
Jefferson George Washington we can't
have a constitution with they made we
have to have a new one that's the
endgame you were on my radio show and I
think this was the most important point
you made that I agreed with that I think
is the most dangerous for the country
because you took on the monument issue
now you can add the NFL issue right and
institutions in this country that are
under fire every day I'll add to that
the two to four year playing of the race
card the the only one of the big weapons
in the PlayBook of the Democrats but
ultimately you say if they get rid of
the monuments they get rid of our
history they can take a knee during the
anthem and diss the flag then ultimately
it's really the Constitution they want
to change that's right I want you to
make that point they're after a they
don't want capitalism they don't want
the electoral college
they don't want white people generally
calling the shots so it they have to
mobilize minority Americans to be angry
you know we do this on Bill O'Reilly
calm almost every night I'm paralleling
you on our website but if you understand
history and most people don't I want to
get to that I don't mean to interrupt
you you know my favorite part of the
game is
usually the end of the game give the
best of the best warriors battling it
out fighting they get in a circle and
they say a prayer bill right this is
actually in football stay right that we
have some breaking news